all right let's do this I usually start
my day around 7:00 or 7:30 in the
morning and once I get up first thing
it's always warm water with lemon and
then obviously it's my babies I have to
take them out for their morning walks I
would say about 20 to 30 minutes long
typically this is maybe she has only
been with us for about one and a half
months she's only six months old she's
not used to the camera she's actually
shaking right now but she's already
thirty kilos so be sure to follow me on
my AG stories because apparently she is
going to grow to 60 to 70 kilos maybe
are you ready yeah look there okay so
rusty he's an attention seeker he loves
to be in front of the camera he loves to
be around you know people okay bye all
right behave yourself okay if it's going
to be a busy day then I like to do a
short 20 to 30 minutes work out in the
morning I like to use my own fitness app
fuel and I would choose the workout of
the day and after a short workout that's
when I will prep a really simple
breakfast you guys know this by now
overnight oats so I've prepped my oats
the night before and I'm just going to
top it up with lots of tropical fruits
as well as chia seeds and nuts I've been
doing this for six years now so I used
to fill my workout videos and everything
you see at home
three years ago I got my own space and I
brought in a team and they have been
helping me not only for my youtube
content but also for my fitness app
basically whatever you see online a lot
of you tend to ask me how do you keep
going especially you know after filming
YouTube content for five to six
I would say that YouTube will always be
there I will always film different types
of fitness content as well as sharing
more of my personal life on YouTube but
my biggest focus right now is my fitness
app the reason why I'm truly determined
to push this forward is because I
believe that through my fitness app I
will be able to share a lot more you for
those of you who have been following me
you you will know that I do a lot of
body weight workout but if you were to
hop onto fear you will find yoga Pilates
booty burn kickboxing basically
different types of workout which you can
still do from the comfort of your own
home and one of the important aspects of
the app is the mindfulness video I
believe that yes it is very important to
train your body but it is equally as
important to train your mind favorite
things in life my dogs they're a huge
part of my life they are pretty much my
babies I love what I do so that is my
favorite thing what I do every day I'm
truly blessed with it I don't feel like
it's a job because I truly enjoy it but
obviously there are days where you will
feel really down really demotivated
you're questioning yourself why are you
doing what you're doing but then when I
realize that it's because I'm reaching
out to people like yourself and
different people around the world who
are looking for the extra push and extra
inspiration to change their life and
health for the better that keeps me
going and that reminds me of my purpose
and my fulfillment in life and thirdly
of course I love to travel
yeah every time I travel I learn
different things I see different people
I explore different cities and it keeps
my perspective fresh I probably say this
in every of my video be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel I really
appreciate all the support and all the
views so be sure to keep watching my
content and I will be sharing a lot more
I would say personal content as well and
don't forget to check out my other
workout videos
I hear us